Colonel I know on October 7th there were
many women and and children um that were
killed now the death toll seeming like
it's above 4,600 people many of them
women and children who have lost their
lives because of Israeli rocket fire how
do you explain that I don't want to
create any parity any human human
suffering is suffering whether it's ours
or theirs the only thing I can say is
that we definitely do not Target
civilians we try to strike militants we
are doing our best to get them out of
Harm's Way we have call on them to
evacuate those who listen to us have a
much better chance of safety those who
don't unfortunately are at risk we will
St still try to operate according to the
laws of uncon conflict and distinguish
between combatant and non-combatant